- I'd right swipe on all of you.
That's like-
- Oh, wow.
- [Nick] That's just a base,
like, you're a beautiful man.
- Really? Thank you.
(all laughing)
(upbeat music)
- I'm the shortest, so.
- Well.
(all laughing)
- [George] Are we really
gonna base on height?
You have to call yourself out like that.
- If we go based on height,
we're gonna look like the AT&T bars.
Like we're just gonna go-
- Honestly, I was gonna
rank you higher up,
'cause I like the tattoos,
and I think that counts as your body.
- That's what I was gonna say.
I think the tattoos, like,
deserve a higher spot.
- I'm looking at chest.
You have the biggest chest as well.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yes.
- Wow.
- I feel like you two would
like go like one or two further.
- Definitely like one and two.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And my leg does play a huge role
in my confidence in myself,
and that's a big reason
why I'm so heavily tattooed
is to draw more attention
away from my leg.
- You are going over there.
- I know where I want to go.
- You too, definitely go over there
- Okay, so, what side do you want me on?
- You are way bigger.
You got the arms,
basically Chris Hemsworth.
(all laughing)
I say Vashon.
- Okay.
- For those calves.
- I think yeah.
- I feel like Tony might be number two.
Just 'cause I feel like if
you lost the weight Nick,
you'd be more defined just
'cause you go to the gym.
I could tell you have muscle,
but I think you have just more
like average body, I'd say.
- Yeah, I'll take it.
- [Michael] Does everyone else agree?
- I would put you number
two in terms of body.
- I feel like I do look
like the most average
out of everybody here,
so I'm okay with that.
- Average isn't a bad thing.
- I go to the gym because
I no longer drink alcohol.
That was like a very bad vice.
I just got four years sober,
so the gym is like my stress reliever.
- Three times a week.
I'm trying to get at least three in
and then, like, an activity of some sort,
whether that be, like, basketball
or just something along those lines.
- Based on that, I feel like you should...
- Because we can see it, we
can see that you work out.
- [Interviewer] How did being up there
in your underwear feel?
- Not great. (laughing)
Didn't love it.
I don't inherently love being shirtless.
I try to stay away from
it as much as possible.
- Yeah?
- I'm good with it, yeah.
- Absolutely.
- Hey good humans, it's Zack.
While I spend a lot of my
time working here at Jubilee,
you can usually find me out and about
with my dance team after the workday ends.
I found that I wasn't getting
all the necessary nutrients
my body needed to keep
up with my busy schedule.
So every morning I make sure
to prepare for the day ahead
with a little help from a
nutritional drink called AG1
by Athletic Greens.
AG1 is a daily micro
habit that makes it easy
to absorb key nutrients,
lead a healthy lifestyle,
and feel your best no matter
how busy your schedule is.
Each scoop of AG1 is nine
health products in one,
giving you the equivalent
of a multivitamin,
minerals, probiotics, and more,
which saves you time and money.
Also, as someone with a
more active lifestyle,
I like to drink AG1,
because it includes key energy
players that work to support
and sustain my energy levels.
Plus, it contains ingredients
that support gut health
and immunity.
Giving your body the nutrients
it needs should be simple.
So take ownership of your health with AG1
by Athletic Greens.
Check out the link in the description
to get a one-year supply of
immune-supporting vitamin D3
and K2, as well as five travel packs free
with your first purchase.
Thank you to AG1 by Athletic Greens
for sponsoring today's episode.
Now let's get into the video.
- No.
- I am very plain.
I don't think I have a style.
This is just gym shorts and a t-shirt.
- You should be number one.
- Okay, I'll take that.
- Definitely the most flashy.
- I know a pose.
- I think it works.
- [Interviewer] Where does
your style come from, George?
- At some point, I got
really tired of, like,
trying to force myself to
be accepted by other guys,
is just such a frustrating
dilemma to, like,
force myself into that I just, like,
started just choosing
what I thought was cool.
Men in skirts like Prince and Kid Cudi.
Queer men, trans men, women,
a lot of women inspire me.
Like, I feel like, you are
inspired by lesbian women.
(record scratch)
- I'm inspired by my girlfriend.
That's who I'm inspired by.
- I would switch you two
because you both have
acceptable like guy, like,
he looks good fashion,
but I like the color.
- Yeah, he definitely put more-
- The earth tone tones.
- Yeah, I was gonna say
though, it's very put together.
- Okay.
- Let's do it.
- I would put you number
two and you number three.
Just because of the colors.
I like the rhine, not
rhinestoning, the sparkling.
- Oh, thank you.
- And you guys put effort
into like jewelry accessories.
- I'm like, so where am I?
- Where am I?
- What's going on?
- You're three.
- Well that's up, do you
all feel okay about that?
Are you cool with number three?
- Yeah.
- I'm so happy that the body
type round was done first.
It allowed me to feel a
little uncomfortable at first,
and then it made me realize
once I did put the clothes on,
how much clothing makes
me feel more beautiful
and attractive.
- I think definitely for me,
more basic stuff is what I like to see
and I think that kinda,
makes a person more attractive for me.
Like, I'm not really into flashy stuff.
I'm sure it's different for you guys,
you guys probably like to stand out.
- Well you guys have the confidence
to rock the stuff that I don't.
The judgment always weighs on me
when I go out in public like that.
- When I was in fourth grade,
I bought a beret at Macy's
that I thought looked so cool.
I wore it to school and I got
made fun of the whole day.
- Hopefully, like, you can find style
and engage with style that you like
and be confident with that.
- I met a friend in high school,
and so he always dressed comfortably
in case he ever had to defend himself,
and I liked that idea, and I was like,
because we kinda grew up
in the same neighborhood,
it made sense.
So I've always liked shorts,
and I always liked a comfortable t-shirt,
in case I had to run away or something.
- I'd love to see you
in a long skirt though.
Like a flowy one too that you can run in.
- I'll give it a shot.
- [George] Go for it.
- You can pick out my next outfit.
- Yeah, we're all going
thrifting after this.
- I wanna change myself
to switching with Nick,
just because, like, based
off of style as well
like, I know you're shocked
right now, but like-
- You think?
- The thing is that, like,
you can see this is as style,
but I see you as style.
I saw it, so that's why.
- He really did, wow okay.
- He volunteers as tribute, I like it.
- I'll take it, I appreciate it.
- We are not our clothes like...
- I do like that, just wear
what you want, you know?
- It's an attitude.
- If you thought like, this
is a very masculine person,
who's like your prime example of?
- The first person that
comes to mind is my stepdad.
He really stepped up and took
my mom in when she was sick,
and took in two stepsons,
my brother and myself.
He has cried in front of me,
he has cried in front of my mom.
I know we separate
femininity and masculinity,
but, like, I think if
you're peak femininity
or peak masculinity,
you're in tune with both
sides of your emotions.
- Honestly, growing up,
masculinity was taught to me as
pretty much just an absence of emotion.
I knew that that was wrong,
so I've just been like
masculinity, femininity,
it's not even real,
we're just taking all
traits that humans can have
and applying a word to it.
So I don't know where I stand.
I'd like to just throw myself at the end.
- I'll go with you
'cause I don't like the
modern version of masculinity,
so I wouldn't associate myself with it.
- Obviously you are very
influenced by your stepdad.
- For sure.
- And if that is your
definition of masculinity
and that's the healthiest
definition I've ever heard,
you deserve to be here.
- I'm on my own journey,
and, like, I still gotta get
my anger under control too.
- Oh I understand,
but you had an opportunity
to look at someone who,
maybe not mastered it,
but understood both sides of the spectrum.
Therefore, I think your upbringing
and your way of seeing things
makes you deserve this spot.
- I like that you said too, you were like,
"I'm still working on it."
If you had told us that,
like, no you're the perfect one already,
you chewed masculinity,
then you wouldn't deserve the top spot.
No one will ever be, like, a perfect man,
but that mindset will
make you a perfect man.
- That means a lot.
That's pretty cool.
- You give dad energy.
(all laughing)
- I am a dad, so I'm trying.
Trying to be better for
my daughter, you know.
So I appreciate, that means a lot.
- Well then get up here, go on.
- I think you deserve that one.
- If I had to make a switch,
I'd switch you and you.
Just vibe honestly.
- I already moved.
- But where do you feel like you belong,
'cause you don't have to
switch if you don't want to.
- I don't know.
I actually don't know.
I think masculinity, like we've said,
is one of these topics
where it is changing every single day.
Like, something new comes
out and then it's like,
oh well it's masculine to do this.
It's not masculine to do this.
And it's like, you know,
it really depends on where
we've been throughout our lives,
what we've experienced and
what we've gone through.
But I think this is a
question that transcends,
you know, six spots.
I think this is something that
we're gonna deal with
for generations still.
- Based on that answer,
and you're admitting
that you are working through your motions,
I don't feel like I'm at that level yet,
so I would put you here based on that one.
- I'd say it all kind of
boils down to, like, hormones,
if that makes sense?
And like testosterone versus estrogen.
- Naturally, our testosterone
levels are going to drop
as we get older.
Does that make us less of
a man in your eyes then?
Because like-
- I don't think less of a man.
I don't think less masculine either.
- Okay, so then should
that be a valid argument
in terms of masculinity?
- I guess when I see a man,
like I was able to see
like kind of straightaway,
like where you guys
stood, if that make sense?
Like I saw you guys as more feminine.
I think a man,
it's more about like
dominance, if that makes sense.
- Do you think I'm less dominant than you?
- It's like facial wise, I
don't know, I can't explain it.
- Facially I'm less dominant than you.
- I guess my definition of masculinity
is more traditional in a sense.
I feel like everyone was maybe
like a more newish, like,
you know, not that there's
anything wrong with that.
And I don't think that's necessarily real,
if that makes sense.
Like realistic, I think
it's, like, ingrained in us.
Like I can't describe it even.
Like when I see someone
you could kind of tell,
if that makes sense.
- Okay, so yeah, you
base it on more physical
and that's totally fine,
yeah, that's totally fine.
- Growing up it was always, like,
either black or white, you know?
Where my parents are like,
"You're masculine, you're super
tough, you're super strong,
and you're there at the
head of the household,
you're always that or
you're like feminine."
So, that's something that
I've always like kind of seen.
That's why I was able to
see both sides of, like,
where Michael was coming from.
- I don't think I deserve the top spot
I really do, like,
after hearing your story
because I obviously I
didn't have that growing up.
I didn't have someone
who stepped into my life
and really like changed my worldview,
and changed my perspective on things.
So that's why I think you
deserve this spot more than I do.
And if you-
- You sure?
- Yes, I'm a 100% sure.
- All right, thank you.
- I think I'm kind of pretty.
(all laughing)
- You have a very nice smile,
that's what I noticed.
- [George] Thank you.
- You have a very, very nice smile.
- I have a lot of moles
and I don't have a lot of
moles on the rest of my body,
it's just all, I just look
like a chocolate chip cookie
and then I got-
- Chocolate chip cookies are hot.
- And then I got my scar
from when I busted my lip
playing tag on crutches,
like, a couple of months
after my amputation.
I think I'm lower on the end for sure.
- [Michael] If I had to say-
- Nah, scars are hot.
- [George] Stay there for a second.
- Stay there.
- Hold up, hold up, hold up.
- You have not been officially switched.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
- So I wouldn't view your
face scar as a bad thing.
- I try to hide mine, but yeah.
- I put you ahead of him.
I put you three, you two, you one for now.
- Okay.
- Sounds good, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Why's that?
- I just think they're more
attractive, to be honest.
- You're into us? (laughing)
- I don't know, like, you
guys both have very nice skin
and so that's why I
think you guys are above-
- I think you do too.
- Well thank you, but...
(George laughs)
- You seem so uncomfortable
with the idea of being judged attractive.
- I'm actually okay with
this spot just because, like,
I have, like, anxiety ticks,
so I tend to pick at my face,
so that's why I have a lot of acne scars.
- I think you have a very
symmetrical face though,
and you have a very bright smile,
so I think you could also be further up.
- I would say that also too.
- I would put you-
- Nice eyes.
- I would put you here, if anything.
How do you guys feel?
Where do you think you belong?
- I think I'm higher.
- [George] Okay.
- I don't wanna be narcissistic.
- If there's ever a time to
be narcissistic, it's now.
- I can look at you
and I could see myself
getting lost in your eyes.
You have very pretty eyes.
- There you go.
- You have, you don't have to do too much,
like you're just attractive,
so I would like to place
you here to my right.
- Sounds good.
- Happy not to be number one.
- You also don't, but there's like,
there's something like-
- Off.
- No, no, no, no, no.
Like, there's something-
- No, like, I say that
because I've had an
underbite my entire life
and I got made fun of
a lot in middle school
and in high school,
and even now, like, on the
internet, that people think
I have features of someone
who has down syndrome,
because of the almond
shaped eyes, the underbite,
kind of just like, this weird looking,
so I'm completely fine staying where I am.
Totally fine with that.
I'm just saying, I get what you mean.
There's just something off.
- Wait, let's talk about
these almond shaped eyes,
because that's always been
a beauty symbol for me.
- Yeah, that's what I keep
hearing in the beauty community.
- Where are you from?
Who's doing this?
Who did this?
- We'll beat them up.
- Give me their names.
- And also just to call out,
even if you had down syndrome,
I don't think that would eliminate you
from being the most
attractive spot at all.
- I agree.
- I think it definitely
helps to know that, like,
other people are not seeing
me the way that I see myself
or I look in the mirror,
and I see everyone who
made those comments.
Whereas, they look at me
for the first time today
and they're like, "You look fine."
- Where would you put yourself here?
And be honest, it's okay.
- I think second to first.
- Second to first.
I think I'd put you third,
because I think your jaw
line's way stronger than mine.
I'd put you right here, personally.
- Any objections?
- No objections.
I think you have really
nice facial features so.
- Appreciate it.
- You're almost like one of those elves
in like "Lord of the Rings"
or something like that.
- [Tony] Oh please.
- [George] Very sharp nose as well.
- We're not getting nerdy here.
- Also, I like your confidence,
like, you have this cool confidence,
and I think that's part
of attractiveness too.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- So I would personally
place you higher up.
I don't know where.
- You're number one, dude.
- Do you wanna be higher?
- Yeah, I feel like, especially, like,
keeping you up in number
one, it's kind of like,
you have the humbleness to yourself.
- That really like resonates well with me,
because, like I said,
I don't like attention,
and it's because I had attention
ever since I had one leg,
when it was amputated at like
five years old, you know?
And that's why I've
never really craved it.
It's just I had unwanted attention
and so just to hear,
like that means a lot.
Like it really does.
You guys are awesome.
I thought I was definitely
gonna rank lower,
but I don't feel like they
ranked me out of my disability,
or out of pity today so, that's
why it feels pretty good.
- I would put you up second,
because we got to hear your story too.
- Yeah, you have a cool story.
- Oh, thanks.
- [Nicholas] I agree.
- There was beauty being
shown all throughout.
- Thanks, thanks, I don't
think I deserve two.
You two, not only do
you know how to dress,
you guys are both bubbly
personalities, you know.
You've got just this glow about both you
that are very warm, inviting presences-
- It's sweat.
- [Nick] It's sweat. (laughing)
- So where would you place yourself?
Like where would you feel like-
- Honestly, five or six.
Like, I'm just a basic white guy.
- I definitely agree you should be higher.
- Just from other like, you
know, people's perspectives,
you really have, like, this good energy
that I feel, like, is really uplifting.
- I appreciate that.
- Let's put you at a
three, how about that?
Not too high, but you know, not too low.
- If I were to place myself,
I would feel like I would
be right next to Vashon,
on the right.
- You guys have more, I feel
like extroverted personalities.
- So you're more introverted.
- Yeah, I'd say.
- [Nicholas] Keep to
yourself kind of dude.
- I'd say Nick should
be higher, personally.
- I disagree.
I think you're a beautiful man.
- This is so hilarious.
- Okay, if we're, if
we're basing it on like-
- Personality and looks yeah.
- If I looked at personality and looks,
and even if I wanted to
boil it down to like,
right swiping or left swiping,
I'd right swipe on all of you.
That's like, that's just a base.
- Oh wow, thank you.
- You're a beautiful man.
- Really?
- I do.
- I wanna see you here.
Really?
- [Nicholas] Rock, paper, scissors.
- Rock, paper scissors, shoot.
Rock, paper scissors, shoot.
That's you.
- No, I won.
I get to stay here.
- What?
- I won, my choice.
- I don't get it.
- Yeah, I feel comfortable.
(upbeat music)
- It says a lot that
this type of situation
can bring six people of
different backgrounds,
different styles, different looks,
and we kind of all worked our way from,
cool, we have basically
seen each other naked to,
I really love your story,
you're so masculine for like
dealing with your trauma
and I just find it very,
therapeutic is the way I would put it.
- I would've never met people
like you, I guess, in my life.
It's definitely a unique experience
to talk with some of you
guys and your personalities.
See what you guys all feel.
- Yeah, I'm glad we got to talk to you.
I'm happy you're here too.
- Likewise.
- It was cool that something so divisive,
like ranking each other
or having to put someone
front, back, last,
just like brought us together somehow,
which doesn't feel like it would,
but I'm happy that I
did this with you guys.
- Hey yes, thank you.
- Alright, give me a hug, give me a hug.
- Male to male validation
is really, really rare.
So, it's honestly kind
of affirming sometimes
when you get validation from other men,
because we so, like, desperately
kind of deprive ourselves
and each other from it.
- Surround yourself with people
who are not only gonna
inspire you to be better,
but people who accept you as you are,
and the people who find you attractive
are the people who see past the
very, you know, first glance
and they look at who you are.